ils étaient plusieurs milliers assez
lancé en fin de matinée dans les rues de
Marseille à Cherbourg
à Pau ou encore Aurillac de nombreux
cortèges mais un seul mot d'ordre la
hausse des salaires les dividendes sont
record
d'après et en bas on sera rationne donc
le match il est là il est le match pour
la justice sociale on demande un speak à
2000 euros ce qui correspond aujourd'hui
à une augmentation de 300 euros
depuis le début de l'année 2022
vous croisez des gens dans la rue
apparemment malgré l'augmentation du
SMIC les fins de mois restent difficiles
on a affaire à des compagnies pétrolière
qui joue sur la vie des Français qui
nous font les poches nous ce que nous
nous demandons c'est de bloquer les prix
de baisser la TVA sur l'essence de faire
en sorte que ça ne devienne pas un luxe
que de faire son plein nous les
jerricanes Sigler LVMH ou Christian Dior
on en veut pas c'est un bras de fer avec
le pouvoir une espèce de Mai 68 perlé
quoi si vous voulez hein parce que
l'agression est tellement féroce que
même les plus indifférents se disent ah
mais quand est-ce qu'ils vont s'arrêter
les gens ils savent pas que que c'est
c'est le plateau de grève vous pouvez
vous pouvez mettre aux gens le plateau
de grève parce que il se rendent pas
compte en fait
ta colère que l'on ressent sur le
terrain est tel qu'il faut absolument
qu'ils entendent c'est une question
vraiment de d'intérêt politique là et
d'intérêt public
une SDF de 24 ans est à l'isolement
depuis la nuit dernière à la prison de
Fresnes les premiers éléments de
l'enquête révèlent un profil
psychologique très instable il y a à
peine un mois
qu'elle a une obligation de quitter le
territoire national donc des choses se
sont faites dans des conditions je crois
qui sont malheureusement non prévisibles
surtout que cette personne est elle-même
manifestement connue comme victime de
violences conjugales le défaut exécution
de ces décisions de justice
rend votre ministère responsable de ces
drames en défendrons-nous nos enfants
contre ces francocytes qui sont toujours
commis par les mêmes toujours au
détriment des mêmes alors là évidemment
on est dans l'instrumentalisation
politique vous n'avez pas pro
cédé d'action c'est une honte monsieur
le député
ne rajoutez pas à l'atrocité la plus
absolue le commerce indigne de la
démagogie et je pense que le meilleur
reste à venir vous ne pourrez pas
évacuer le sujet comme vous le faites en
toute circonstance et comme vient de le
faire le ministre de l'injustice en
criant à la récupération et en attaquant
par cet argument éculé ceux qui sont
scandalisés
et je suis ravi de
cette récompense
[Applaudissements]
et de délit
[Musique]
es renvoyés chez eux cabineuf deux
lettres et un chiffre qui resteront dans
l'histoire du football 24 ans après
Zidane Karim Benzema ramène un nouveau
ballon d'or à la France félicitations à
lui vous en pensez quoi du tweet de
Jordan Bardella qui a retweeté manuel
Macron sur
Lola quel est le rapport ah ben le
rapport c'est qu'on a un président de la
République qui est sur des sujets légers
alors qu'il se passe des choses graves
sur le dans notre pays ce ballon d'or
comme je le dis c'est
c'est individuel mais ça reste collectif
c'est pour ça que moi pour moi c'est le
Ballon d'Or du peuple voilà
Marine Le Pen un mot sur Karim Benzema
Jordan Bardella sur Karim Benzema
je sélectionneur des Bleus Didier
Deschamps ou encore Kylian Mbappé on
subit de nombreux tacles sur Twitter un
sport qui déchaîne les passions des
mauvaises langues